- [Instructor] Tara was
hiking up a mountain.
She started her hike at an
elevation of 1,200 meters
and ascended at a constant rate.
After four hours, she reached
an elevation of 1,700 meters.
Let y represent Tara's elevation
in meters after x hours.
And they ask us, and this is from
an exercise on Khan Academy, it says,
complete the equation for the relationship
between the elevation
and the number of hours.
And if you're on Khan
Academy, you would type it in,
but we can do it by hand.
So pause this video and
work it out on some paper
and let's see if we get to the same place.
All right, now let's do this together.
So first of all, they tell us
that she's ascending at a constant rate.
So that's a pretty good indication
that we could describe her elevation
based on the number of hours she travels
with a linear equation.
And we could even figure
out that constant rate.
It says that she goes from 1,200 meters
to 1,700 meters in four hours.
So we could say her rate
is going to be her change in elevation
over a change in time.
So her change in elevation is 1,700 meters
minus 1,200 meters and she
does this over four hours.
Over, her change in time is four hours.
So her constant rate
in the numerator here,
1,700 minus 1,200 is 500 meters.
She's able to go up 500
meters in four hours.
If we divide 500 by four,
this is 125 meters per hour.
And so we could use this now
to think about what our equation would be.
Our elevation y would be equal to,
well, where is she starting?
Well, it's starting at 1,200 meters.
So she's starting at 1,200 meters.
And then to that, we're going to add
how much she climbs based on
how many hours she's traveled.
So it's going to be this rate,
125 meters per hour times
the number of hours she has been hiking.
So the number of hours is x times x.
So this right over here is an equation
for the relationship between the elevation
and the number of hours.
Another way you could
have thought about it,
you could have said, okay,
this is going to be a linear equation
because she's ascending
at a constant rate.
You could say the slope intercept form
for a linear equation is
y is equal to mx plus b,
where b is your y-intercept.
What is the value of y
when x is equal to zero?
And you'd say, all right,
when x is equal to zero,
she's at an elevation of 1,200.
And then m is our slope.
So that's the rate at which
our elevation is increasing.
And that's what we
calculated right over here.
Our slope is 125 meters per hour.
So notice, these are equivalent.
I just have, these two terms are swapped.
So we could either write
y is equal to 1,200
plus 125x or you could write
it the other way around.
You could write 125x plus 1,200.
They are equivalent.